under the scorching Greek sun Lazarus
shows us the effect it's having on his
crops they are not the same some small
some big they should be the same also
this is burnt from the Sun all these are
lost produce this is proof that climate
change is real whoever doesn't believe
it here it is lettuce burnt by the Sun
we visit on a record-breaking weekend
temperatures well into the 40s not seen
in Greece for 50 years
since 1991 we have gradually had an
increase in temperature of 10 degrees
during the summer also the seasons have
changed we used to have four seasons now
we only have two winter and summer with
extreme weather phenomena this has
resulted in us having problems in our
crop
Now farmers are very much on the front
line of climate change changes in
temperature and rainfall have a direct
impact on the soil and how it grows or
doesn't grow their crops now they tell
us that they're having to adapt and that
of course comes at a cost they have to
do things differently now spring onion
seeds used to be sown straight into the
ground outside now they first plant them
in a greenhouse away from the harsh Rays
until they are strong enough to be
planted outside
just one way they've had to change it
costs more and the produce is less
in the late afternoon heat local farmers
rest under the shade of a large tree
Costa's gikas says he's been farming
since he was seven he is now 80 years
old
the temperature has changed very much
I'll tell my grandchildren not to start
farming they won't be able to make a
living once the temperature goes over 40
everything dies it's like with humans
you do nothing and you still sweat I
planted Tomatoes months ago and they're
all destroyed now they don't need
scientists to tell them the planet is
warming for them it's a first-hand fact
everything has already changed Stephanie
Decker aljazeera marathonas in Greece